le cinéma c'est quelque chose qui m'a
toujours tenté qui m'a toujours plu qui
va toujours passionné disons que c'est
les moyens qui manquent et d'en faire
le film de godard on a aimé on n'a pas
aimé mais en tout cas bon j'étais dedans
et puis et puis ça s'est passé comme ça
s'est passé
et puis et puis j'ai fait une pub avec
costa et puis je ne suis pas pour la
suite moi je sais que j'adorerais
tourner aucune des coffrages moi je sais
que personnellement j'aime le film de
costa traditionnel c'est un film c'est
un film très c'est la vie d'une famille
quoi une famille un petit peu
particulière mais la vie d'une famille
il ya des moments qui me touche comme
dans toute histoire de famille et puis
puis j'espère que j'espère d'abord faire
d'autres films j'espère aussi g4 tout ça